[Music]
the Vikings came from the rugged
inhospitable north known today as
Scandinavia as the Roman Empire
flourished further south Scandinavians
had small settlements no central
government and no coinage yet by the
11th century the Vikings had spread far
from Scandinavia gaining control of
trade routes throughout Europe
conquering kingdoms as far as Africa and
even building outposts in North America
the secret to their success was their
ships the formidable Viking longship had
its origins in the humble dugout canoe
or log boat for millennia the
inhabitants of Scandinavia had used
these canoes for transportation dense
forests and tall mountains made overland
travel difficult but long coastlines and
numerous rivers lakes and fjords
provided a viable alternative
the first canoes were simply
hollowed-out logs rowed with paddles
over time they added planks to the log
boat base using the clinker or lap
strake technique meaning the planks
overlapped and were fastened to each
other along their edges as the Roman
Empire expanded north some Scandinavians
served in their new neighbors armies and
brought home Roman maritime technology
the Mediterranean cultures at the heart
of the Roman Empire had large warships
that controlled the sea and cargo ships
that transported goods along the
waterways these ships were powered by
sail and oars and relied on a strong
skeleton of internal Timbers fastened to
the outer planks with copper iron and
wood nails at first Scandinavians
incorporated this new technology by
replacing their loose paddles with
anchored oars this change hugely
improved the crews efficiency but also
required stronger ships so boat builders
began to use iron nails for fasteners
rather than sewing they abandoned the
log boat base for a keel plank and the
boats became higher and more seaworthy
but these early ships retain
to the concept of the original log boat
their strength depended on the outer
shell of wood not internal frames and
beams they were built as shells thin
walled but strong and much lighter than
the Roman ships competing chieftains
quickly refined the new ships to be even
more efficient the lighter the boat the
more versatile it would be and the less
investment of resources it would require
an essential advantage in a
decentralized culture without large
supplies of people these ships still had
no sales sales were costly and for now
the road ships could meet their needs
that changed after the Western Roman
Empire collapsed in the 5th century
Western Europe took a heavy economic
blow levelling the playing field a bit
for the Scandinavians as the region
revived new and vigorous trade routes
extended into and through Scandinavia
the wealth that flowed along these
routes helped create a new more
prosperous and powerful class of
Scandinavians whose members competed
constantly with each other over trade
routes and territory by the eighth
century a sailing ship began to make
sense it could go further faster in
search of newly available plunder with
the addition of sails the already light
and speedy ships became nearly
unbeatable the Viking ship was born
Viking longships could soon carry as
many as 100 Vikings to battle fleets of
them could land on open beaches
penetrate deep into river systems and be
moved overland if need be when not at
war the vessels were used to transport
goods and make trade journeys there were
smaller versions for fishing and local
excursions and larger adaptations for
open sea voyages capable of carrying
tens of tons of cargo
thanks to their inventiveness in the
face of difficult terrain and weak
economies the Vikings sailed west
settled the North Atlantic and explored
the North American coasts centuries
before any other Europeans would set
foot there
Viking ships aren't the only relatively
simple innovation that had a huge impact
on human history
take for example gunpowder which was
originally invented to try and make
humans immortal or T a Chinese
innovation that became so popular that
trade disputes sparked a war with the
British Empire
[Music]